homework 1 hard deadlines section
tomorrow we're going to go through the
backpropagation example which I went
through very briefly in the last lecture
talk about nearest neighbors which I did
in one minute
and also they're going to talk about
scikit-learn which is this really useful
tool for doing machine learning which
might be useful for your final projects
good to know
so please come to section alright let's
do a little bit of review of where we
are so we've talked about we're talking
about machine learning in particular
supervised learning where we start with
feature extraction where we take
examples and convert them into a feature
vector which is more amenable for a
learning algorithm we can take either
linear predictors or neural networks
which gives us scores and the score is
either defined via a simple dot product
between the weight vector and the
feature vector or some sort of more
fancy nonlinear combination the end of
the day we have these model families
that gives us you know score functions
which then can be used for a
classification or regression we also
talked about loss functions as a way to
assess the quality of a particular
predictor so in linear classification we
had the zero M loss and the hinge loss
as example of loss functions that we
might care about the training loss is an
average over the losses on individual
examples and to optimize both of this we
can use the stochastic gradient
algorithm which takes an example X Y and
computes the gradient on that particular
example and then just updates know the
weights based on that ok so hopefully
this should be all no review ok so now
I'm gonna ask the following question you
know let's be a little bit philosophical
here so what is the true objective you
know of machine learning
so how many of you think it is to
minimize the error on the training set
show of hands
no one this is what we've been talking
about right we've been talking about
minimizing your on training sets okay
well maybe that's maybe that's not right
then what about minimizing training
error with rigor ization because
rigorous a ssin is probably a good idea
how many of you think that's that's a
goal
what about minimizing error on a test
set okay seems like it's closer right
you know test sets test accuracies or
things maybe you care about what about
minimizing ear on unseen future examples
okay so the majority of you think that's
the right answer
and what about learning about machines
that's a true objective who doesn't want
to learn about machines that's actually
the true objective No so the correct
answer is minimizing error on unseen
future examples so I think all of you
have an intuition that we are doing some
machine learning we're learning on data
but we really care about is how this
predictor performs on in the future
because we're gonna deploy this in a
system and it's going to be the future
it's gonna be unseen and then but then
okay so then how do we do you think
about all these other things no training
said regularization in test sets so
that's going to be something we'll come
back to later okay so there's two topics
today I want to talk about
generalization which is I think a pretty
subtle but an important thing to keep in
mind when you're doing machine learning
and then we're gonna switch gears and
talk about unsupervised learning where
we don't have labels but we can still do
something so we've been talking about
training loss right we've you know I've
made a big deal about you write down
what you want and then you're optimize
so the question is like is this training
loss a good objective function well
let's take this literally suppose we
really wanted to just minimize the
training loss what would we do well
here's here's an algorithm for you so
you just store your training examples
okay and then you're gonna define your
predictor is as follows so if you see
that particular example in your training
set then you're just going to output the
output that way you saw in the training
set and then otherwise you just gonna
stick phone these are gonna crash right
so this is great it minimizes the
training error perfectly it gets zero
loss assuming your training examples
don't have conflicts but you know you're
all laughing because this is clearly a
bad idea
so somehow purely following this
minimizing training set objective our
objective is not really the right thing
um so this is an example a very extreme
example of overfitting
so overfitting is this phenomena that
you see where you have some data and
usually the data has some noise and you
are trying to fit a predictor but you're
really trying too hard right so if
you're fitting this green squiggly line
you are fitting the data and getting
zero training error but you're kind of
missing the big picture which is you
know this black curve or incorrect
regression some of you probably seen
examples where you have a bunch of
points usually with noise and if you
really try hard to fit the points and
you can't get zero error but you're kind
of missing this general trend and
overfitting can really kind of bite you
if you're not careful so let's try to
formula formalize this a little bit more
how do we assess whether a predictor is
good because we can't measure it we
can't really know optimize it okay so
the key idea is that we really care
about error on unseen future examples
okay so this is great as you know
aspiration to write down but the
question is how do we actually you know
optimize this right because it's the
future and it's also unseen so you know
our definition we can't get a handle
didn't have
so typically what people do is the next
best thing which is you gather a test
set which is supposed to be
representative of the types of things
you would see and then you guard it
carefully and make sure you don't touch
it too much right because you know what
happens if you start looking at a test
set and know what the worst case that
you train on a test set right so you
know the test set being a surrogate for
unseen future examples just completely
goes away right and even if you start
looking at any of your you know really
try and optimize it you can get you know
two into this overfitting regime right
so really be careful of that and I want
to emphasize that the test set is really
a surrogate for what you actually care
about
so don't blindly just you know try to
make test accuracy numbers go up at at
all cost okay okay so but for now let's
assume we have a test set though you
know we have to work with so you know
there's this kind of really peculiar
thing about machine learning which is
this leap of faith right you the
training algorithm is only operating on
a training set and then all of a sudden
you go to these unseen examples or the
test set and you're expected to do well
so you know why is there why would you
expect that you know to happen and as I
alluded to on the first day of class
there's some kind of actually pretty
deep of mathematical reasons for why
this might happen
but you know rather getting into the
math I just kind of want to give you a
maybe intuitive picture of how to think
about this this gap okay so remember we
have this picture that it's of all
predictors so these are all the
functions that you possibly want in your
wildest dreams and then when you define
a feature extractor or a neural net
architecture or any sort of
no structure you're basically saying hey
I'm only interested in these set a
function not all functions okay and that
learning is trying to find some element
of the class of functions F that you've
set out to fine okay
so there's a decomposition which is
useful so let's take a at this point G
so G is going to be the best function in
this class the best predictor that you
can possibly go so if some Oracle came
and set your neural net weights to
something how well could you do okay so
now there's two gaps here one is the
approximation error the approximation
error is the difference between f star
which is the true predictor so this is
you know the thing that always gets the
right answer and G which is the best
thing in your class okay so this really
measures how good is your hypothesis
class remember last time we said that we
want hypothesis class to be expressive
if you only have linear you know
functions and your data looks sinusoidal
then that's not expressive enough to
capture the the data okay so the second
part is estimation error this is the
difference between the best thing in
your hypothesis class and the the
function you actually find right and
this measures how good is a learned
predictor and relative to the potential
of the hypothesis class you define this
hypothesis classes here are things that
I'm willing to consider but at the end
the day based on a finite amount of data
you you can't get to G you only can kind
of estimate you know some you do
learning and you get to some F hat so in
the kind of more mathematical terms if
you look at the error of the thing that
your learning algorithm actually returns
minus the error of the your best thing
possible which you know many cases is
you know zero then this
written as follows so all I'm doing is
minor subtracting era of GM adding era
of G so this is the same quantity as
this but then I can look at these two
terms so the estimation error is the
difference in error between the thing
that you're learning algorithm produces
- the best thing in the class G and then
the difference approximation error is
the difference between error of G and
error of F sorry okay so this is going
to be useful as a way to kind of
conceptualize the different trade-offs
right so you know just to kind of
explore this a little bit suppose I
increase the hypothesis class size right
so I add more features or I you know
added increase the dimension on my
neural networks what what happens so the
approximation error will go down and why
is that because we're taking a minimum
over a larger set so what G is always
the minimum possible error over the set
F and if I make the set larger I have
just more possibilities of driving there
down okay so the approximation error is
going to go down but the estimation
error is going to go up right as I make
my hypothesis class more expressive and
that's because it's harder to estimate
something more complex so I'm leaving a
kind of a vague right now there's a
mathematical way to formalize this which
you can ask me about offline
okay so you can see this kind of tension
here right you really want to make your
hypothesis class large so you can drive
down the approximation error but you
don't want to make it too large that it
becomes impossible to estimate okay so
now we have this kind of abstract
framework what are some kind of knobs we
can turn how do we control the size of
the hypothesis class so we're going to
talk about two centric classes of types
of ways so strategy 1 is dimensionality
so remember for linear classifiers a
predictor is specified by a weight
vector so this is d numbers right and we
can change D we can make these smaller
by removing features we can make the
larger by adding features and
pictorially you can think about as
reducing D as reducing the
dimensionality of your of your
hypothesis class so if you were in three
dimensions you have three numbers three
degrees of freedom you have this kind of
ball and you if you remove one of the
dimensions now you have this you know
ball or circle in two dimensions okay so
concretely what this means is you can
manually add you know this is a little
bit heuristic you can add features if
they seem to be no helping and remove
features if they don't help so you can
you know kind of modulate the
dimensionality of your weight vector or
there are also automatic feature
selection methods such as your boosting
or l1 regularization which are outside
the scope of this this class could be if
you take a machine learning class you'll
learn more about this the stuff but the
main point is that you can determine by
setting the number of features you have
you can vary the expressive power of
your hypothesis
okay so the second strategy is looking
at the norm or the norm or the length of
a vector so this one is maybe a little
bit less you know obvious so again for
linear predictors the weight vector is
just a DNA match from vector and you
look at how long this vector has so what
is and the length pictorially looks like
this so if you have let's say all the
weight vectors in know each W can be
about as a point as well so this circle
contains all the wave vectors up to a
certain length and if by making the
smaller now you're considering you know
a smaller number of wave vectors okay so
at that level it's perhaps intuitive so
what does this actually look like so
let's suppose we're doing one
dimensional linear regression here's the
board and we're looking at X Y so
remember what and in one dimension we're
all we're looking at is you know W is
just a single number right and the
number represents the slope of this line
so by saying um no let's draw some
slopes here okay so by saying that the
weight vector or the weight is a small
magnitude that's basically saying the
slope is no smaller or closer to zero so
if you think about you know slope equals
let's say this is slope equals one so W
equals one so anything-anything let's
say less than 1 or greater than minus
one is fair okay and now if you reduce
this to half now you're looking at a
kind of a smaller window here and if you
keep on reducing it now you're basically
converging to you know essentially very
flat and constant functions
okay so you can understand this two ways
one is just that the total number of
possible weight vectors you're
considering is just shrinking because
you're putting more constraints they
have to be you know smaller from this
picture you can also think about it as
what you're really doing is making the
function
you know smoother right because a flat
function is the kind of the smoothest
you know function it doesn't kind of
vary too much and a complicated function
is one that can go you know very jump up
very steeply and you know for quadratic
functions can also come down really
quickly so you get kind of very Wiggly
functions those are tend to be more
complicated okay any questions about
this so far yeah what if we have like
like instructors within the data sets
that sense of track that sense we kind
of like not over fit we're really just
kind of like these drinking ourselves
like a parenthesis or a set of like
distributions that we say okay the state
of must have like come from like
something normal must have come from
something reasonable but by saying that
we're like not really capturing the full
the full like scope apart so the
question is if there's particular
structure inside your data set for
example if some things are sparse or you
know low rank or something you know how
do you capture that with a
regularization
realization but you have like perhaps
not not even just like president lakes
watch like this like if you have like
calls a models inside decided between
year like parameters like how would you
like what a recognization like impede
some of those relations yeah so so all
this is kind of very generic right
you're not making any assumptions about
there's what the classifier is or the
features so they're kind of like big
hammers that you can just apply so if
you have models where you have more
structure or domain knowledge or if you
which will see you know for example if
you have you know Bayesian networks
later in the class
then there's much more you can do and
this is just kind of you know two
techniques for as a kind of generic way
of controlling for overfitting yeah
[Music]
this approach is actually putting
constraints on each element in factor W
like the magnitude of it versus the
other one that's actually how many
elements are in yeah so um so let's look
at W here so let's say you're in three
dimensions so W is w1 w2 w3 um so the
first method just says okay let's just
kill some of these elements and make it
smaller this one is saying that
I mean formally it's looking at the
squared values of each of these and
looking at the square root that's what
the norm is so it's saying that each of
these should be you know small according
to this particular metric yeah
yeah so that's why I'm going get to so
this is just kind of giving you
intuition for in terms of hypothesis
classes and how you want them to be
small how do you actually implement this
you know there's several ways to do this
but the most popular way is to add
regularization and buy regularization
what I mean is take your original
objective function which is trained loss
of W and you just add this penalty term
so lambda is called the regularization
strength it's just a positive number
let's say let's say 1 and this is the
squared length of W ok so what this is
doing is by adding this it's saying that
ok optimizer you should really try to
make trained loss small but you should
also try to make this small as well okay
and there's a if you study convex
optimization there's kind of this to the
duality between this this is called the
Lagrangian form where you have a
penalized objective where you add a
penalty on the wave vector and the
constraint form where you just say that
I want to minimize training loss with
subject to the norm of W being less than
some value but this is more than kind of
a typical one that you're going to see
in in practice
okay so here's objective function great
how do i optimize it
yeah I CW there and paint losses further
minimizing yeah so it's important that
these be the same W and you're
optimizing the Sun so the optimizer is
gonna make these trade-offs if it says
oh okay I can drive the training loss
down but if this is shooting up then
that's not good and they'll try to
balance these two it's it's basically
saying try to fit the data but not at
the expense of having huge weight
vectors so if there's another way to say
it is that kind of think about Occam's
razor it's saying if there's a simple
way to fit your data then you should
just do that instead of finding some
really complicated weight vector that
fits your data so prefer simple
solutions okay so once you have this
objective you know we have a standard
crank we can turn to turn this into
algorithm you can just do gradient
descent and the you know if you just
take the derivative of this then you
have this gradient and then you also
have lambda W which is the gradient of
this term so you can understand this is
basically you're doing gradient descent
as we were doing before and now all
you're doing is you're shrinking the
weights towards zero by lambda so lambda
is a regularization strength if it's
large that means you're trying to really
kind of push down on the magnitude of
weights so the great optimizer is
basically going to say hey I'm going to
try to step in the direction that makes
the training law small but then I'm
going to also you know push the weights
towards zero okay in neural nets
literature this is also known as so
weight decay and you know optimization
statistics it's known as l2
regularization because this is you know
the Euclidian or two norm
okay so here here is another strategy
which intuitively gets at the same idea
but it's in some sense you know more
crude so it's called early stopping and
the idea is very simple you just stop
early instead of going and training for
100 iterations you just train for you
know 50 ok so why why does this why is
this a good idea
um the intuition is that you know if you
start with the weights at zero so that's
the smallest you can make the norm of W
right so every time you update on the
training you know set generally the norm
goes up you know there's no guarantee
that it will always go up but generally
this is what happens so if you stop
early that means you you're giving less
of an opportunity for the norm to your
grow grow so fewer updates translates to
generally lower norm you can also make
this formal mathematically but you know
the connection is not as tight as the
explicit regularization from the
previous slide okay so the lesson here
is you know try to minimize the training
error but don't try you know too hard
yeah question depends on how we
initialize the weights
question is does this depend on how we
initialize the weights most of the time
you're going to initialize the weights
from you know some sort of weights which
is kind of a baseline either zero or you
know for neural nets maybe like random
vectors around zero but they're pretty
small weights and usually the weights
grow from you know outside from small to
large there's other cases where if you
think about you know pre-training you
have a pre-trained model you start with
some ways and then you do gradient
descent from that then you're saying
basically don't go too far from your
initialization right so the question is
why aren't we focusing on minimizing the
train loss or why focus on W it's always
going to be a combination so the
optimizer is still trying to push down
on the training loss by taking these
gradient updates I noticed that the the
cranium with respect to the Reg riser
actually doesn't come in here it kind of
comes in explicitly through the fact
that you're stopping it early but it's
always kind of a balance between
minimizing the training loss and also
making sure your class classifier
weights doesn't get too complicated yeah
[Music]
I decide what value of lambda or
intersect yeah so the question is how
you decide the value of T here and how
you decide the value of lambda so we
pull up hyper parameters and I'll talk a
little bit more about that later okay so
here's the kind of the general
philosophy that you should have any
machine learning is you should try to
minimize the training error because
really that's the only thing you can do
that's your data and that's you know you
have your data there but you should try
to do so in a way that keeps your
hypothesis small so trying to minimize
the training set error but don't try too
hard
I guess as that is the lesson here okay
so now going back to the question
earlier if you notice through all these
my presentation there's there's all
sorts of properties of the learning
algorithm you know which feature you
have which regularization parameter you
have the number of iterations the step
size for gradient descent these are all
considered hyper parameters so so far
they're just magical values that are
given to the learning algorithm and the
learning algorithm runs with them but
someone has to set them and how do you
set them yeah you can ask me I don't
know the answer to that ok so here
here's an idea so let's choose a high
parameters to minimize the training
error so how many of you think that's a
good idea
okay not too many so why is this a bad
idea
yeah you can overfit right so suppose
you took lambda and you say hey you know
let's choose a lamb that I will minimize
the training error okay and the learning
algorithm says well okay
you know I want to make this day go down
what is this doing in the way let's just
settle I'm to the zero and then I don't
have to worry about this so it's kind of
you know cheating in a way and also
early stopping would say like don't stop
just keep on going because you're always
going to drive the training error lower
and lower okay so that's not good so how
about choosing high parameters to
minimize the test error I mean you say
yeah it's a good idea yeah nuts not so
good it turns out so why and this is
again stressing the point that the test
error is not the thing you care about
because what happens when you look at it
we try to use a test set then it becomes
an unreliable estimate of the actual
unseen error because if you're tuning
hyper parameters on a test set that
means that it's no longer it becomes
less and less unseen and less future
[Music]
yeah so we could do cross validation
which I'll describe in a second okay
so I want to emphasize this point when
you're doing your final project you have
your test set you have it sitting there
and you should not be you know failing
way that too much or else it becomes
less reliable okay so you can't use a
test set so what do you do so here's
idea behind a validation set is that you
take your training set and you sacrifice
some amount of it maybe it's you know
10% maybe it's 20% and you use it to
estimate the tester so this is a
validation set right the tests they're
set is you know off to the side it's
locked in a safe you know it's you're
not gonna touch it and then you're just
gonna tune hyper parameters on the
validation set and use that to guide
your model of development yeah
[Music]
the proportion itself it's a hyper hyper
parameter no I you yeah you don't
usually don't do that I mean usually
it's how you choose it is kind of this
balance between you want the validation
set to be large enough so it gives you
reliable estimates but you also want to
use most of your data for training yeah
yeah so how do you choose the hyper
parameters so the the answer is you try
particular values so you for example try
let's say lambda equals point zero one
and point one one and then you run your
algorithm and then you look at your
validation error and then you just
choose the one that has the lowest yeah
it's pretty crude yeah way to choose it
to choose like the linear rates and I
get a hyper parameters without just
doing like a like a like a search alert
you try this one then try this one yeah
so how is there a better way to search
for hyper parameters you could do your
grid search generally is fine random
sampling is fine there's fancier things
based on Bayesian optimization which
might give you some benefits but it's
actually the jury's out on that and
they're more complicated there's also
you can use better learning algorithms
which are less sensitive to the step
size so you don't have to nail is like
0.1 works but black point one one
doesn't so you don't you don't want that
but in all the high-level answer is that
there's no real kind of principled way
of like here's a formula that lambda
equals and you just evaluate that
formula and you're done because there's
this is you know the kind of the I don't
know the dirty side of machine learn
there's always this tuning that needs to
happen to get your good results yeah
question
tricky kind of is this process usually
automated or so the question is is this
process automated increasingly it
becomes much more automated so it
requires a fair amount of compute right
because usually if you have a large dish
that even training one model might take
all the while and now you're talking
about you know training let's say 100
models so it can be very expensive and
there's things that you can do to make
it faster but I mean in general I would
advise that don't hype a pro mattoon
kind of blindly especially when you're
kind of learning the ropes I think do we
are kind of manually and getting
intuition for what step size like
effective step sizing algorithm is still
valuable to have and then once you kind
of get a hang of it then maybe you can
automate but I wouldn't try to automate
- yeah yeah so the question is if you
change the hyper parameters a little bit
and that causes your training or model
performance to change quite a bit
does that mean your model is not robust
yeah it means your model is probably not
as robust and sometimes you actually
don't choose to have a hyper premise at
all and you still get varying you know
model performances so yo you should
always check that first because there
could be just inherent randomness
especially if you're doing neural
networks it could get stuck in local
optimum there's all sorts of you know
things that can happen okay final
question in now move on
I could they optimal have a burger it
just went there converging to certainly
so how do you choose a optimal
hyperparameters so you basically have
like a for loop that says for lambda in
you know point one point zero one one
and whatever values for T equals you
know something you train on this all
these training examples - validation and
then you test the model on the
validation you get a number and you just
use whichever setting gives you the
lowest number I'm sorry we do know the
numbers it's not just like we usually
you just have to be in the ballpark you
don't have to get like 99 versus 100 the
things I would just advise is like you
know let's say what kind of orders of
magnitude because if it if it really
matters like being down to the precise
number then you probably have other
things to worry about okay let's move on
so what I'm gonna do now is go through a
kind of a sample problem right because I
think the the theory of machine learning
and the practice is a are actually kind
of quite different in terms of the types
of things that you have to think about
so here's a simplified named entity
recognition problem so named entity is
this recognition is this Y popular task
in NLP where you're trying to find names
of people and locations of organizations
so the input is a string where which has
you know a particular potential you name
with the left and right contacts words
okay and the goal is to predict whether
this X contains you know either a person
which is plus one or not okay so so
here's the the recipe for success when
you're doing your final project or
something
you get a dataset it have if it hasn't
been already split split it into
training validation and test and lock
the test set away and then first I would
try to look at the data to get some new
intuition you know I'll always remember
you want to make sure that you
understand near your data don't just
immediately start coding up the most
fancy algorithm you can think of and
then you repeat you implement some you
know feature maybe you change the
architecture of your network and then
you tune some you set some hyper
parameters and you run the learning
algorithm and then you look at the the
training error and validation error
rates to see you know how they're doing
if you're under fitting or overfitting
in some cases you can look at the
weights further than your classifiers
and for neural nets it might be a little
bit harder and then you I would
recommend look at the predictions of
your model I always have I always try to
log as much information as I have you
can so that you can go back and
understand what the model is you know
trying to do and then you brainstorm
some improvements and you kind of do
this until you either are happy or you
run out of time and then you run it on
the final test set and you get your
final iterates what you put in your
report okay so let's go through an
example of what this might look like so
this is going to be based on the code
base for the sentiment homework so okay
so here's where we're starting we're
reading a training set let's look at
this training set so there are you know
7,000 lines here each line contains the
label which is minus 1 or plus 1 along
with the input which is going to be you
know remember the left context the
actual entity and the right
okay all right so you also have a
development or validation set and what
this code does is it's going to learn a
predictor which takes the training set
and a feature extractor which we're
gonna fill out and then it's going to
output either both though the weights
and some air analysis which we can look
to use to look at the predictions and
finally there's this test which I'm
gonna not do for now
okay so so the first thing is let's
define this feature extractor so this
feature extractor is V of X and we're
going to use the sparse you know map
representation of features so the feed
is there's this really nice commune
structure called default dict so this is
kind of like saying you have a you know
a your map but you can you know access
it and if the element isn't there then
you return 0 okay Sophie it goes that
and then return field okay so this is
the simplest feature vector you can come
up with the dimensionality is 0 because
you have no features ok so but you know
we can run this and see how we do on
this ok so let's run this ok so over a
number of iterations you can see that
learning isn't do anything because
there's no white stuff update ok so but
you know it doesn't crash which is good
ok so I'm getting 72% error which is you
know pretty bad but I haven't really
done anything so that's to be expected
ok where my window go ok so now let's
start defining some new features ok so
remember what is X X is something like
took Mauritius in two right so there's
this this entity and left and right so
let's break this up so I'm going to
tokens equals x split so that's going to
give me a bunch of tokens and then I'm
going to define left entity right equals
so this is the token 0 is the left
that's going to be took tokens 1 through
minus 1 is going to be everything until
the last soak in and then tokens minus 1
is the last one ok so now I can define a
feature template so remember a good nice
way to go about it is to find your
future template so I can just say entity
is and blank that's how I would have
write written it as a feature template
in code this is actually pretty no
transparent it's saying I'm defining a
feature which is going to be 1 for this
you know feature template so entity is
going to be some value I plug it in I
get a particular feature of value or
feature name and I'm gonna set that
feature name tip you have the feature
value 1 okay so let's run this ok so
let's go over here run it whoops so
entity is a list so I'm going to just
going to turn into a string
okay so now I'm getting what happened so
the the training error is pretty low
right I'm basically fitting the training
error pre trains that pretty well but no
notice I I don't remember I don't care
about the training sir I care about the
tester so just one note it says test
here but it's really the validation
Chicago change that it's just whatever
non training said you passed it okay so
this is still a twenty percent error
which is not great okay so at this point
remember I want to go back and look at
some you know get some intuition for
what's going on here so let's look at
the weights okay so this is the weight
vector that's learned so for this weight
feature the weight is one and all of
these are 1 and this know corresponds to
the names that the people names that
have been seen that training time
because whenever I see a person name
that I'm going to you know give that
feature a 1 so I can get that training
example right if you look at the bottom
these are the entities which are not
people that's okay so this is sanity
check that it's doing what it's supposed
to do so the nice thing about with these
kind of really interpretive that you can
kind of almost compute the what the
weight should be in your in your head
yeah
each or every almost every example the
German yeah yeah yeah so I have look
essentially one feature for every entity
which is almost you know number yeah so
there's a 3900 so we're gonna change
those but we'll get we're not there
okay so okay so the other thing we want
to look at is the error analysis okay so
this shows you here's an example Eduardo
Romero the ground truth is positive but
we predicted minus one and why do we
predict minus one it's because this
feature has weight zero and why does it
have way zero because we never saw this
name at training time okay but you do
get some right
we saw Senate at training time and we
rightly predicted that was minus one
okay but you know you look at these
errands you say okay well you know this
is maybe the we should add more features
okay so if you look remember this new
example here maybe the context helps
right because if you have governor blank
then you probably know it's a person
because only people can you know be
governors so let's add a feature so I'm
gonna add a feature which is left is
left and for symmetry I'll just add
right is right okay so this defines them
indicated features on you know the
context so in this case would be tooken
into okay so now if three feature
templates let's go and train this model
and now I'm down to I just love in
percent error okay so I'm making some
progress
oops
let's look at the error analysis okay so
now I'm getting this correct
and let's look at what else am I getting
wrong so Smith is blamed you know Felix
mantilla and you know again it hasn't
seen this execs actually maybe did see
this string before but it so got it
wrong you know I think there's a kind of
a general intuition though that well if
you have you know Felix you know even if
it you've never seen Felix mantilla if
you see Felix something you know chances
are probably as a person not always but
as as we you know noted before features
are not meant to be like deterministic
rules they're just pieces of information
which are useful so let's go over here
and we want to define let's say a
feature for every possible word that's
in in entities a word and entity
remember entity is a list of tokens
which occurred between left and right
and I'm gonna say entity contains word
okay
so now let's run this again and now I'm
down to you know 6% error which is you
know a lot better if you look at the
error analysis so I think the maybe the
Felix example and now I get this right
and you know what else what else can I
do
so you know what I'm kind of this
general strategy here I'm following here
is you know which is not always the
necessary the right one but you start
with kind of very very specific features
and then you try to kind of generalize
you know as you go so how can I
generalize this more right so if you
look at worker so Kurdistan right if
your word ends in Stan or then I mean
maybe it's less likely to be a person I
actually don't know but you know maybe
like suffixes and prefixes are helpful
too so I'm going to add features let's
say entity contains prefix and then I'm
going to let's say just you know
heuristic we look at the first four
tokens and suffix the last four tokens
and then run this again and now I'm down
to four percent error okay okay
I'm probably gonna you know stop right
now at this point you can actually run
out on your test set and we get you know
four percent error as well yeah
oh yeah I guess this was all planned out
so that the test error would go down but
actually more often than not you're at a
feature that you really really think
should help but it doesn't help for
whatever reason so yeah yeah some of the
time you do it doesn't move that's kind
of probably them more of the time but
sometimes it can go up if you add a
really you know bad future so the more
features you add generally the trainer
will go down right so all the algorithm
a knows is like it's driving training
are down so it doesn't know that it
doesn't know generalize yeah okay so
this is definitely the happy path I
think when you go and actually do
machine learning it's going to be more
often than not the tests error will not
go down so don't get too frustrated just
keep on trying yeah we expect to keep
optimizing after like are you expected
to optimize after 5% error it's it
really depends you know there's kind of
a limit to every data set so data sets
have noise so sometimes you you should
definitely not optimize below the noise
limit so one thing that you might
imagine is for example you have an
Oracle which let's say it's human
agreement like if your data set is
annotated by humans and if humans can
team agree like three percent of the
time then you can't really do better
than three percent of the time as a
general rule there are exceptions
[Music]
okay any other questions yeah do all
your training happy energy - into a real
application say in the end then you town
or test that you find it's not good oh
yeah what happens if you actually you
try on the test set and it's not good
that's you just say that it's not good
so there's many things that could happen
one is that your test set might actually
be different for whatever reason maybe
it was collected in a different day and
your performance just doesn't hold up on
that test set in that case well that's
your test error right remember the test
error is just if you didn't look at it
it's really an honest representation of
how good the small is and if it's not
good well that's just the true there was
a your model it's not that good in some
cases there's some like bug like
something was missed processed in a way
and it wasn't really fair so you know
there are cases where you wanted like
investigative it's like way off the mark
if I had gone like 70 percent error then
maybe something was wrong and you would
have to go investigate but if it's in
the ballpark and whatever it is that's
kind of what you have to deal with right
so what you want to do also is make sure
your validation error is kind of
representative of your if your test
error so that you don't have you know
surprises at the end of a day right I
mean it's I think fine to run it on a
test set just to make sure that there's
no catastrophic problems but the the
kind of aggressive tuning on a test that
is something that would you know have
warned against yeah and these are the
scanners
you should split the data into train
about and validation of testing German
like what percentage of your day that
you should allocate to each one just
randomize daily yeah so question is how
do you split into train validation it
depends on how large your data set is so
generally people you know shuffle the
data and then randomly split it into
test validation and train maybe let's
say like 80 percent 10 percent 10
percent just as a kind of a there are
cases where you don't want to do that
there's cases where you for example want
to train on the past and test on the
future because that simulates the more
realistic settings remember the test set
is meant to kind of be representative as
possible of the situations that you
would see in the real world so the
question is the data set was labeled
there's 7,000 of them I personally did
not label this data set this is a
standard data set that someone labeled
you know sometimes these data sets come
from you know crowd workers sometimes
they come from you know experts
yeah sometimes they come from grad soon
it's actually a good exercise to go in
label I've labeled a lot of data you
know also in my life yeah exactly
okay let's go on so switching gears now
let's talk about unsupervised learning
so so far we talked about supervised
learning where the training set contains
input output pairs so you're given the
input and this is the output that your
predictor should output but you know
this is very timely we were just talking
about how fully labeled data is very
expensive to obtain because you know the
7,000 is actually not that much you know
you can often have you know hundred
thousand or even a million examples
which you do not want to
be sitting down and annotating yourself
so here's another possibility
so unsupervised learning non-super by
learning the training data only contains
inputs and unlabeled data is much
cheaper to obtain in certain situations
so for example if you're doing text
classification you have a lot of text
out there people write a lot on the
internet and you can easily download you
know gigabytes of text and all that is
on labeled and you can do something with
it that would be you know you turn that
it's gold or something and also images
videos and so on you know it's not
always possible to obtain unlabeled data
for example if you have you know some
device that is producing data and you
only have one of that device that you
built yourself then you know you're not
gonna be able to get that much data but
we're going to focus on a case where you
do have basically infinite amount of
data and you want to do something with
it so here's some examples I want to
share with you this is a classic example
from NLP that goes back to you know the
early 90s so this idea of word
clustering the employee you have a bunch
of raw text lots of news articles and
you put into this algorithm which I'm
not going to describe but I'm gonna look
at we're gonna look at the output so
what is this output it returns a bunch
of clusters where for each cluster it
has a certain set of words associated
with that cluster okay you look at the
clusters the pretty coherent so this is
roughly the first cluster is days of a
week second cluster is months third
cluster is some sort of you know
materials fourth cluster is synonyms of
like no big and so on and you know one
thing one thing the critical thing to
note is that the input was just raw text
nowhere did someone say hey this these
are days of the month learned them and
now go test you later it's all
unsupervised
so this is actually you know on a
personal note the kind of the example
when I was doing a master's that got me
into doing an LP research because I was
looking at that sounds like well you can
actually take unlabeled data and
actually mine really interesting kind of
signals out of it more recently there's
these things called war vectors which do
something very similar instead of
clustering words they embed words in
into a vector space so if you zoom in
here each word is associated with a
particular position and words which are
similar actually happen to be close by
in vector space so for example these are
country names these are pronouns these
are you know years months and so on okay
so this is kind of operating on a very
similar principle there's also
contextualized word vectors like Elmo
and Bert if you've heard of those things
which have been really taking the NLP
community by storm more recently on the
vision side you also have the ability to
do unsupervised learning so this is an
example from 2015 where you run a
clustering algorithm which is also
jointly learning the features during
this kind of deep neural network and it
can identify different types of digits
zeros and nines and fours that look like
nines threes and/or 5sy look like threes
and so on so remember this is not doing
classification right you're not telling
that algorithm here's our five series
our twos it's just looking at examples
and finding the structure that oh these
are kind of the same thing and these are
also the same thing and sometimes but
not always these clusters actually
correspond to labels so here's another
example of ships planes and birds that
look like planes so you can see kind of
this is not doing classification it's
just kind of looking at visual
similarity
okay alright so the general idea behind
supervised learning is that you know
data has a lot of rich latent structure
in it and that by that mean I mean
there's there's kind of patterns in
there and we want to develop methods
that can discover this structure you
know automatically so there's multiple
types of unsupervised learning there's
clustering dimensionality reduction but
we're gonna focus on you know clustering
in particular k-means clustering for
this lecture okay so let's get into it
more formally so the definition of
clustering is as follows
I give you a set of points so x1 through
xn and you want to output an assignment
of each point to a cluster and the
assignment variables are going to be z1
through Zn so for every data point I'm
gonna have a zi that tells me which of
the K clusters I'm in 1 through K ok so
pictorially this looks like this board
here where I have let's say let's say I
have 7 points okay and if it gave you
only these 7 points and I tell you hey I
want you to pluster them into two
clusters
you know intuitively you can kind of see
maybe there's a left cluster over here
and the right cluster over here ok but
how do we formulate that kind of
mathematically so here's the k-means
objective function so this is the
principle by which we're going to derive
clusterings okay so k-means says that
every cluster there's gonna be two
cluster is going to be associated with a
central okay so I'm gonna draw a
centroid in a red square here and the
centroid is a point in this space along
with you know the data points and I'm
gonna this is kind of representing where
the cluster is and then I'm going to
associate each of the points with a
particular centroid so I'm going to
denote this by a blue arrow pointing
from the point into the centroid and you
know these two quantities are going to
kind of represent the clustering I have
the locations of the clusterings in red
and also the assignments of the points
into the clusters in in blue okay so of
course neither the red or the blue are
known and that's something we're gonna
have to optimize okay so but first we
have to define what the optimization
objective function is so intuitively
what do we want we want each point of V
of X I to be close to the centroid right
for the centroid to be really
representative like of the points in
that cluster that centroid should be
close to all the points in that cluster
okay so this is captured by this
objective function where I look at all
the points for every point I measure the
distance between that point and the
centroid that that point is associated
with it so we remember Zi is a number
between 1 and K so that indexes which of
the mu mu 1 or mu 2 I'm talking about
I'm looking at the squared distance
between those two the centroid on the
point yeah
yeah yeah how does each point get to
assign to a centroid so that's going to
be specified by the Z's which is going
to be optimized over paper you don't
know yeah question is do we know how
many clusters there are in general no so
there are ways to select it's another
hyper parameter so it's a something that
you have to set before you run the
k-means object function so when you're
tuning you try different number of
clusters and see which one kind of works
better okay so we need to choose the
centroids and assignments jointly so go
this this hopefully is clear you just
want to find the Simon's e and the
centroids mu to make this number as
small as possible so how do you do this
well let's let's a look at a simple
one-dimensional example and let's build
up some so we're going 1d now and we
have four points and the points are at
they're going to be at zero to ten and
twelve okay so I have a points for
points at these locations okay I want a
cluster and intuitively you think I want
two clusters here there's going to be
two centroids and suppose I know the
centroids okay so I just someone told
you magically that the central this
example is are going to be like at one
and eleven okay so someone told you that
and now you have to figure out the
assignments you know how would you do
this
[Music]
well let's assign this point where
should it go
you look at this distance which is one
you look at this distance which is 11
and which are smaller one is smaller so
you say okay that's where I should go
same with this point one is smaller for
these eleven and smaller and that's okay
so mathematically you can see it's
comparing the distance from each point
to each of the center's and choosing the
center which is closest okay and you can
convince yourselves that that's the way
to if the cluster centers were centroids
were fixed how you would minimize the
objective function because if you choose
a center which is farther away then you
get just you know a larger value and you
want the value to be as small as
possible okay I don't know why this is
true I think this should be one right
okay
near alpha okay so let's do it the other
way now suppose I now have the
assignments so I know that these two
should be in some cluster these two
should be in a different cluster cluster
two and now I have to place the the
center's you know where where should I
paste that should I place it here should
I place it here Shea place it here you
know we're shy placement and if you look
at the despite here what you're doing is
you're saying okay for the first cluster
I know two and zero are assigned to that
cluster and I know that the the sum of
the distances to this the centroid amou
is this and I want this number to be as
small as you know possible okay and if
you do the first homework you know that
you know whenever you have one of these
kind of squared up some objectives you
should it be averaging the points here
so you can actually solve that in closed
form and you given the assignments here
you know the center should be there
which is average of 0 & 2
and for these this cluster you should
average the two points here and that
should be at 11 yeah
okay so what's the difference between
centroid and assignment so when you're
clustering you have K clusters so
there's K centroids so in this case
there's two centroids
there's no those are the red the
assignments are association between the
points and the centroids so you have n
assignments we then these are the things
[Music]
yes okay here is a hyper parameter which
is a number of clusters which you can
turn okay so here's a chicken-and-egg
problem right if I knew the centroids I
could pretty easily come up with
assignments and if I knew the
assignments I could come up with the
centroids but I don't know either one so
how do I get started so the key idea
here is alternate minimization which is
this general idea in optimization which
is usually you know not a bad idea and
the principle is well you have a hard
problem maybe you can solve it by
tackling kind of two easy problems here
so here's a k-means algorithm so step
one is you're going to you're given the
centroids now kind of go into more
general notation mu 1 to MU K and I want
to figure out the assignments so for
every data point I'm going to assign
that data point to the cluster with a
closest centroid so here I'm looking at
all the clusters 1 through K and I'm
going to test how far is that point from
that centroid and I'm just going to take
the smallest value and that's going to
be where I assign that point
okay step two flip it around you're
given the cluster assignments now is you
1 through Zn and now we're trying to
find the best centroids so what centroid
should I pick so now you go through each
cluster one two okay
and you're going to set the centroid of
the case cluster to the average of the
points assigned to cluster right so
mathematically this looks like that
you're just sum over all the points I
which have been assigned to cluster K
and you add you basically add up all the
the feature vectors and then you just
divide by the number of things you
summed over okay so putting it together
if you want to optimize this objective
function the k-means reconstruction loss
first you initialize mu1 from UK
randomly there's many ways to do this
and then you just iterate set the
assignments given the clusters centroids
and then set the centroids given the
cluster assignments there's alternate
yeah see how this makes sense for like
coordinates for like images where like
if you read in a similar image by bytes
it looks the same like words where words
that are spelled totally differently can
have like these same like semantic
meanings how do you accurately map them
to like a same location to cluster
essentially around yeah so the question
is like maybe four images distances in
your pixel space makes kind of more more
sense but if you have words than you
know two words which you shouldn't be
looking at like the Edit distance
between you know though are the words
and two synonyms like a big and large
look very different but they're somehow
similar so this is something that word
vectors you know address which we're not
going to you know talk about basically
you want to capture
the representation of a word by its
context so the context in which big and
large occur is going to be kind of
similar and you can construct these
context vectors that give you a better
representation we can talk more offline
yeah yeah you can get stuck and I'll
show you an example okay any other
questions about the general algorithm
yeah yeah yeah maybe I'll answer that
I'll sure example yeah so this is going
up to a fixed number of iterations T
typically you would have some sort of
you board monitor this objective
function and once it gets below it stops
changing very much then you just stop
actually this so the k-means algorithm
is guaranteed to always converge to a
local minimum so I just should be this
demo and I think it'll be make some
things clear okay so here I have a bunch
of points so this is a JavaScript demo
you can go in and play around and change
the points if you want it's linked off
the course website and then I'm gonna
run k-means okay so I initialize with
these three centroids and these regions
are basically the points that would be a
sign to that centroid so this is a
Voronoi diagram of these centroids okay
and this is the loss function which
hopefully should be going down okay so
now I iterate so iteration one I'm gonna
assign the points to the clusters so
these get assigned to blue this one gets
assigned red these gets assigned to
green and then the step two is going to
be optimizing the centroids so given all
the blue
I put the center in the smack in the
middle of these blue points and then
same with green and red notice that now
these points are in the red region so if
I reassign then these become red and
then I can iterate and then you know
keep on going and you can see that the
algorithm you know eventually you know
converges to clustering where these
points are blue these points are red and
these are green and if you keep on
running it you're not going to make any
progress because if the assignments
don't change then the cluster centroids
are going to change either okay so let
me actually you know skip this since I'm
it's just gonna do it on the board but I
think you kind of get the idea
so let's talk about this a local minimum
problem so k-means is not guarantee is
is guaranteed to converge to a local
minimum but it's not guaranteed to come
find a global minimum so if you think
about this as a toy visualization of
objective function you know by going
down here you can get stuck here but it
won't get to that point so it's the
example for different random seeds you
can let's say you initialize here okay
so now all the three centers are here
and if I run this and I run this now I
get this other solution which is
actually a lot worse remember the other
one was 44 and this is 114 and that's
where the algorithm converge and you're
just stuck so in practice people are
typically try different initializations
run it from different random points and
then just take the best there's also a
particular way of initialisation called
k-means plus plus where you put down a
point and you put down a point which is
as far this way as possible and then as
far as where as possible and then that
kind of spreads out the center's so they
don't kind of in
interfere with each other and that
generator works pretty well but still
there's no necessary guarantee of
converging to the
goalball optimum ok any questions about
k-means yeah how do you choose k you
guys love these hyper parameter tuning
questions so one thing you can kind of
bra is the picture so k and then give a
loss that you get from k and usually if
you have one cluster the loss is going
to be very high and that at some point
it's you know going to go down and you
generally you know lop it off when it's
you know not going down by very much so
you can monitor that curve another thing
you can do is you have a validation set
and you can measure reconstruction error
on that you know validation set and
choose the minimum based on that which
is just another hyper primer that you
can do yeah
how is the training loss calculated so
the training loss is this quantity so
you sum over all your you know points
and then you look at the distance
between that point and the assigned
centroid and you square that and you
just add all those numbers up okay so to
wrap up oh actually I haven't you have
more slides here uh-huh
[Music]
unsupervised learning you're trying to
leverage a lot of data and we can kind
of get around this difficult
optimization problem by you know doing
this alternate minimization so these
will be quick so just to kind of
summarize the learning section we've
talked about feature extraction and I
want you to think about the hypothesis
class that's defined by a set of
features prediction which boils down to
kind of what kind of model you're
looking at for classification and
regression supervised learning you have
linear models or neural networks and for
clustering you have you know with a
k-means object objective you have loss
functions which you know in many cases
all you need to do is compute the
gradient and then there's generalization
which is what we talked about for the
first half of this lecture which is
really important to think about you know
the test said remember is kind of only a
surrogate for unseen future examples so
a lot of these ideas that we've
presented are actually quite old so the
idea of least squares you know the for
regression goes back to you know Gauss
when he was you know solve trying to
solve some astronomy problem logistic
regression was you know from statistics
in AI there was actually some learning
that was done even in the you know in
the 50s for playing checkers as I
mentioned the first day of class there
was a period where learning kind of fell
out of favor but it came back with back
propagation and then much of the 90s
actually a lot more kind of rigorous
treatment of optimization
you know formalization of when
algorithms are guaranteed you know
converge that that happened in 90s and
then in a 2000's you know we know that
people looked at kind of structure
prediction and there was a revival of
neural networks some things that we
haven't covered here are you know
feedback loops right so learning assumes
kind of the static view where you take
data you train a model and then you go
in generate predictions but if you
deploy the system in the real world
those predictions are actually going to
come around and be data and those
feedback loops can also cause your
problems that you might not be aware of
if you're only thinking about ah here's
I'm doing my machine learn anything you
know how can you build classifiers that
don't discriminate so we often have
classifiers you're minimizing the
training set average of a training set
so but by a kind of construction you're
trying to drive down the losses of you
know kind of common examples but often
you get these situations where minority
groups actually get you know pretty high
loss because they look different and
almost look like outliers but you're not
really able to fit them but the training
loss doesn't kind of know care so
there's other ways there's techniques
like distribution robust optimization
that tries to get around some of these
issues there's also privacy concerns how
can you learn actually if you don't have
access to entire data set so there's
some techniques based on randomization
that can help you and then Inter bility
how can you understand what you know the
algorithms are doing especially if you
have a deep neural network you've learn
a model and there's no work which I am
happy to discuss with you offline so the
general so we've concluded three
lectures on machine learning but I want
you kind of to think about learning in
the most general way possible which is
that you know programs should improve
with you know experience right so I
think we've talked about you know linear
classifiers and all these kind of nuts
and bolts of basically reflex models but
in the next lectures we're going to see
how learning can be used in state-based
models and also you know variable based
models okay with that so that concludes
next week dorso will be giving the
lecture on state-based models